in the ice bucket fill it with ice get
it cold
i wanted to be hospitable when mr kelly
arrived offered him an ice cold beverage
i had no idea what this man was going to
do would he come in the room
would he look at me and say no i'm not
talking to you and walk away or would he
attack me or whatever in any event i was
going to be
hospitable and say you know what you
care for a cold beverage
so she said it on the dresser
and the way the room happened to be
if you're standing in the hallway right
there by the door looking into the room
you cannot see who's in the room you
have to walk into the room turn to your
right
and go around the corner and the room is
like laid out back there
you know as soon as you walk in the in
the door there's a wall right there
in the bathroom right here so
you go around the wall and then you see
the room um
it just happens to be how it was how it
was designed so i took advantage of that
i took the little lamp table
and took the lamp off and put it over
here in the far corner of the room
lab table no no bigger than that thing
okay right
and you know they don't have big tables
and hotel rooms right just something
like that yeah i put a chair on one side
and shown the other side one for me one
for him
and um i'm in the most obscure corner of
the room
so you don't you don't see me until you
come halfway into my room
and i had a black canvas bag by my chair
in which i had a cassette recorder
i put it in the middle of the table all
in hopes that he would come in the room
and he would allow me to record our
interview and i also had and i had some
blank cassettes
and i had a copy of the bible because ku
klux klan
claims to be a christian organization
they claim that the bible preaches
racial separation
now in my reading of the bible i've
never seen that in there
so i wanted to be able to you know pull
out my bible and say here mr kelly
please
show me chapter and verse where it says
blacks and whites must be separate
so i'm all prepared right right on time
5 15 was the time
mary hops up and runs around the corner
to open the door
i'm seated at my table where you can't
see me until you come in the room
she opens the door and in walks the
grand
nighthawk nighthawk means bodyguard
security
so a grand night i'll teach you all the
names
so a grand nighthawk is the bodyguard to
the grand dragon
an imperial nighthawk would be the
bodyguard to the imperial wizard okay so
okay so in walks this grand nighthawk
he's wearing military camouflage with
that ku klux klan patch right here that
red circle
white cross blood drop over here are the
letters kkk
and embroidered on his beret said
knights of the ku klux klan
and he has a semi-automatic handgun in
his holster right here
he comes in and mr kelly is walking
directly behind him
in a dark blue suit and tie and carrying
a briefcase
well the nighthawk turned the corner and
saw me and just froze
stopped dead in his tracks and mr kelly
did not realize
that his guy had stopped short and
slammed into his back and knocked him
forward
so now they both are stumbling around
trying to you know regain their balance
and they're like looking all around the
room in the bathroom you know
and i'm just sitting there at the table
like you know looking at them they think
they're being set up
yeah you know i could read their faces
you know they were thinking
you know did we misunderstand the room
number from the desk clerk or is this an
ambush
you know and so i realized that
apprehension so i stood up and i
displayed my palms
you know in order to say i don't have
anything on me you know and i walked
forward i said hi mr kelly i'm daryl
davis
and he shook my hand and the nighthawk
shook my hand
i said come on in please come on in they
came in
i said have you seen mr kelly and he sat
down and the nighthawk stood at
attention to his right
and before i could sit down mr kelly
says mr davis
do you have any form of identification i
said sure
i gave him my driver's license he goes
oh
you live on such-and-such street in
silver spring well now that had me
concerned
why is he looking at my street address
is he going to come burn across on my
lawn or what
all he needs to do is look at my picture
look at my name match it up to me
and give me back my license here he is
reciting my street right
you know i wasn't quite sure how to
handle that and because you know that
had had unnerved me a little bit
he was trying to like threaten you or
something well i didn't know what you
know why is he recalling you know
calling off my street
and so i said to him i said yes mr kelly
i said that is where i live
i said and you live that and i named his
house number and his street
that way he knew that i knew where he
lived too whoa so i'm leveling the
playing field if you come visit me
i'm gonna come visit you so he smiled he
nodded his head
like he understood now i did not find
out that day
it was many many months later that i had
been presumptuous i had no reason to
fear
mr kelly coming to my house right what
it was was
one of his members i didn't even know
this at the time
one of his members lived right down the
road from me and mr kelly would have to
travel down my street
because my street goes through my
neighborhood and goes two neighborhoods
over
where this other guy lived so mr kelly
recognized my street that's all
so it's a long street that runs down
there wow so um and
he lives like an hour and a half from me
mr kelly does but but he has members all
around you know
is he is he still alive mr kelly yeah
yeah okay yeah
so anyway um he recognized the street
name
now today that same member isn't is in
the federal prison he is there for a
long time
for committing a hate crime so that that
would happen later
anyway uh we got on with this interview
and um you know he would make statements
uh that were biblical or whatever if you
know when he did
i'd reach down to pull out my bible to
make him prove it
and if my cassette ran out of tape i'd
reach down get a fresh cassette
and every time i reach like this the
nighthawk reached like this
and but that's his job you know he has
no idea what's in my bag you know he
doesn't know me i'm the enemy
and so so every time you reach down and
grab a cassette out of your bag
he's reaching up he'd reach up for his
gun yeah he never pulled it
but he put his hand on the butt of the
gun okay right
so he's doing his job i mean that's his
job to protect his boss he doesn't know
me
he has no idea what's in my bag well
after a while or so he realized you know
there was nothing threatening in the bag
and he relaxed okay and i went in and
out of the bag he didn't move
all right a little over an hour into
this interview
um we were just talking like you and i
are right now
and out of nowhere this random noise
happened
it was very short but very fast i got
that was it
that was it and you know
i flew out of my chair and i hit the
table
and we all jumped but
it happened so fast and was so short
that my ear could not discern what it
was
you know but i knew that mr kelly had
made the noise
and how did i know that because i didn't
make it
so process of elimination if i didn't do
it he had to have done it right
right and because i couldn't figure out
what it was
i perceived it to be an ominous
threatening noise
and understand you know the tension i'm
a black guy he's the head of the clan
you know and we're sitting here in this
room i've already been told by some
former clansmen he you know he would
kill me
not to fool with him so you know i'm on
high alert
and now some he's making some weird
noise for no reason
so i feared for my life i've gone into
what you call survival mode
and when you go into survival mode
people will generally do
one of four things some people they will
just pass out they'll faint
because the fear is so great their brain
cannot process it
and just shuts down they pass out right
it's like somebody saw a ghost and they
faint
they can't process that um another thing
people will do
is their muscles will tighten up and
they'll constrict and they can't they
can't move they're
like this you ever see anybody get into
a fight and they curl up into a fetal
ball and people can be hitting them and
kicking them and they're not even
deflecting the blows
they're like this uh because their
muscles have become paralyzed
uh that's called um paralysis by fear
they just constrict i don't do that
either the third thing that people
will have an option to do is to run away
you know
which is the best option it's the option
that i would have taken
had it been available as quickly as you
can
separate yourself from the source of the
fear
all right uh run away and or put as much
distance between yourself and the fear
as you can as quickly as you can um that
was not an option for me because
how am i going to outrun a bullet in a
motel room i'm not armed
mary is not armed the only person who i
know for sure is armed
is the nighthawk i can see his gun on
his hip
i did not know if mr kelly had a weapon
up under his suit jacket
or not so the next option you have
is to do a pre-emptive strike get them
before they get you
and that's what i was about to do when i
came out of my chair i was going to dive
across the table
grab the nighthawk grab mr kelly and
slam them down to the ground
and take away the nighthawks gun jesus
didn't mobilize
well i didn't want to die that day you
know you know it's
you know you know you're you're in
survival mode you will do whatever you
have to do to survive
and um it's my job to protect me and
protect my secretary
like mr nighthawks job to protect
himself and his boss
so i was gonna you know immobilize you
know the situation
but when i hit the table i was looking
right into mr kelly's eyes
and i didn't say a word to him but my
eyes were speaking loud and clear
my eyes were saying to him and i knew he
could read my eyes
we're saying to him what did you just do
but the thing was his eyes had fixated
on mine
and i could read his eyes too and his
eyes were saying to me
what did you just do and then i thought
he's standing there like this
looking back and forth between both of
us like what did either one of y'all
just do
right so
mary was sitting to my left on top of
the dresser
because there were no more chairs and
she realized what had happened
and she began explaining it when it
happened again
the ice in the ice bucket had begun
melting and the cans of soda
were shifting down the ice oh my god
that was it
how ridiculous is that somebody almost
got shot over a damn ice cube
seriously that's how crazy it was
tension was
that thick time even after an
hour of talking yeah and because because
of that random noise
okay but this is but there was a lesson
learned here well i'll put it this way
it wasn't learned at that moment it was
taught
at that moment be learned later okay um
but you know we all began laughing when
you know when she began explaining it
right and we were laughing at how
ignorant we all had been
um which in a sense made us all human
beings
you know yeah he's in the clan i'm a
black guy but we're human beings
we're laughing at the same stupidity and
same ignorance that we all experience
we all experience fear we all experience
that ignorance
you know and we all experience laughter
all in in the same moments
right so you know we humanize one
another in that in that uh in that sense
so the lesson taught is this ignorance
breeds fear all right all because
some foreign and underscore
highlight circle of the word foreign
entity
of which we were ignorant that being the
bucket of ice cans of soda
had entered into our little comfort zone
via the noise that it made
we became fearful of each other okay
we knew the bucket was over there we
were long forgotten about it right so
you know we were ignorant to it and it
it it made its presence known by making
some weird noise
you know that we didn't understand so um
ignorance breeds fear we fear those
things we don't understand
and we didn't understand what that noise
was so we feared it
um if you don't keep that fear in check
that fear will escalate and breed hatred
because we hate the things that frighten
us if you don't keep that hatred in
check
that will escalate into anger and then
breed destruction
we want to destroy the things that we
get angry about and hate
um and why do we hate them because they
frighten us but guess what
at the end of the day they may have been
harmless and we were just ignorant
so ignorance breeds fear fear breeds
hatred
hatred breeds destruction and we saw the
whole chain
almost unravel to completion the last
component being destruction
it stopped just short of that you know
had the nighthawk pull out his gun and
shot somebody
namely me or my secretary doing his job
or had i pounced across the table
and hurt one of them doing my job um